et on utilise ici près de 4 millions de
doses ou 4 millions de personnes ont
reçu une première dose du vaccin le pays
sort d'une quatrième vague de
contaminations l'aide internationale a
permis de renflouer les stocks du sérum
aujourd'hui samedi 4e journée nationale
de vaccination intensive notamment
consacré au corps militaire les
précisions de notre reporter sur place
d'un seul chez dix
nouvelles journées nationales de
vaccination à travers tout le pays la 4e
depuis le 8 août dernier une journée
consacrée à l'injection de la deuxième
dose de sérum anti virus aux plus de 40
ans la priorité sera donnée cette fois
ci aux forces armées invités à se
vacciner massivement 340 centres ont été
aménagés à travers tout le territoire
pour assurer le bon déroulement de cette
journée placée sous le signe de la lutte
anti virus seul rempart contre une
nouvelle recrudescence de cas dans le
pays et à la proche de la rentrée
scolaire le ministère de la santé a
annoncé que les collégiens âgés de 12 à
14 ans pourront se voir administrer
leurs premières doses de sérum
directement dans les établissements
scolaires par des agents assermentés du
ministère de la santé quant aux élèves
du lycée qui n'ont pas pu se rendre aux
différentes journées nationales de
vaccination
ils bénéficieront du même service dans
leur établissement annonce le ministère
de la santé selon les autorités de santé
publique plus d'un million et demi de
tunisiens ont terminé leur cycle
vaccinale en date du 1er septembre
l'objectif fixé par le gouvernement
d'atteindre d'immunité collective est
encore loin mais les autorités
tunisiennes constate néanmoins une
stabilisation de la situation
épidémiologique avec un taux de
positivité de 17 6% de quoi respirer un
automne un peu plus serein pour un pays
qui a été sévèrement touché tout au long
de l'été